You are gonna have the most amazing birthday weekend.
Wow!
I haven't had the opportunity to come to New York and just enjoy it...
...in a way that I got to with this trip.
And certainly, New York is a strong city.
We were there to try to find survivors...
...and when our task force arrived in Ground Zero,...
...I just couldn't believe the magnitude.
I was just so grateful to have a canine partner that helped me get through it.
We're so thrilled to have you here at 1 Hotel Central Park...
...and we are even more excited to have Bretagne as our first Pup of Honor here.
Happy birthday.
Bretagne, look!
Happy birthday, sweetie.
Wow!
Surprise!
Happy birthday, Bretagne!
Oh my gosh, what have you got here, Bretagne?
A lot of dog handlers say you get that one dog and I've had several canine partners,...
...but Bretagne is that one dog for me.